my name is Eric Jarvis I'm an associate
professor at Duke University Medical
Center I'm also a Howard Hughes Medical
Institute investigator and I'm going to
be talking to you today about why I
became a scientist and how I became a
scientist just to let you know I right
now I run a laboratory that runs roughly
has anywhere from 15 to 20 persons
depending on the semester and we study
brain pathways for vocal learning but
that's not how I begin so I grew up in
New York City mostly in the Bronx and
queens and I grew up in a family that
came from diverse economic backgrounds
from being relatively poor middle class
and we always were told you know to have
a dream in life to make your life better
to do something important but most of my
family was into the performing arts
particularly on my mother's side and so
we were all dreaming to be you know
famous artists singers and dancers and
so forth and you know to just do this
with a passion and so when I was a
youngster in elementary school and
eventually going to high school I
auditioned for the High School of
Performing Arts and got to be a dance
major there and I then also was at the
Joffrey Ballet School in New York City
and the Alvin Ailey Dance Company and I
was pushing along to be a serious dancer
and I would dance six hours a day of
three hours at school three hours at one
of these dance schools and in between
would have academic classes like you
know math biology reading writing and so
on some point towards the end of my high
school years I started really thinking
about you know is this the career I want
to pursue and I was doing okay and for
instance in my senior year towards the
end of that year I was asked to audition
for
Alvin Ailey Dance School I mean the the
the company and I was asking myself what
do I really want to do in life and I
started asking like that question
because my mother always said to me it
doesn't really matter what you do what's
most important is that what you do you
do it well and she would then add but
I'd like you to do something that has a
positive impact on society and I thought
you know what can I do that has a
positive impact on society and I felt I
could do that better as a scientist then
I could do that as a dancer so so in my
senior dance concert right at the end of
the dance concert I'm thinking making
this decision here and I said you know
what I'd like to go ahead and be a
scientist and I didn't have any
scientific background training at all I
had biology classes which I really liked
so I applied to different colleges got
into Hunter college and actually you had
to take remedial courses because they
said I wasn't prepared enough to take
the advanced academic classes so I took
a summer of remedial classes and then
really started intensively studying
biology and mathematics like I was
studying dance and the reason why I was
studying biology and math is because I
felt I wasn't sure if I really liked
biology better or let's say that is the
understanding of how biological
organisms work or the origins of the
universe those are my two major interest
so I decided to do both and I thought
math would actually helped me think
better so then after my first year I got
into a program that helps
underrepresented minorities get into
scientific research and this was a great
advantage that I discovered later offset
a disadvantage that I had that I didn't
realize many other people had and then I
really worked with a passion in the lab
I would sometimes spend a night in the
lab do experiments on the weekends on
the holidays and people calling up where
is Eric where is Eric where can we find
him in the lab that's where he was and I
fell in love with doing scientific
research in the lab like I did as a
dancer and people often asked
well how how did you make that switch
aren't those two different fields very
different and I discovered at that time
no they're not both of them require a
lot of discipline both of them require a
lot of hard work both of them require
acceptance of failure that is you have
to do a choreographed dance over and
over and over again until you get it
right just like an experiment sometimes
if you submit a paper for a publication
it gets rejected sometimes you go for an
edition you get rejected so you have to
learn how to accept rejection and try
over again and importantly both of them
require a good level of creativity as an
artist you need to be creative to have
your art be appreciated by others you
need to come up with something new same
thing for science you need to be
creative to understand how nature works
and so to me dance and science was a
natural merge of two different fields
then when I was at Hunter College where
I did my undergraduate scientific
research and also academic training I
decided what do I want to do
particularly within science for my
future career and I decided you know
what I really am interested in two
questions one is the origins of the
universe and the other is how the brain
works and in trying to choose between
those two I chose I to study how the
brain works
why because I felt it was more rooted in
my dance background that is more wooden
in something here in the earth and as
result of that I applied to different
graduate schools and I got into a number
of them because from all the hard work I
did as an undergraduate student I was
able to publish six papers in scientific
journals either as you know first author
papers or collaborative papers with
others in the lab and that helped me
become competitive to get into some good
graduate school programs I was trying to
decide do I want to do an MD PhD or a
to answer this question about brain
function and I decided on the PhD
because usually the PhDs are the folks
who actually make the discoveries to
understand how things work or the cures
for diseases so I went to Rockefeller
University as a graduate student and I
began to study the songbird brain and
discovered genes that are regulated in
those areas that either control the
neural circuits for forming learned
vocalizations or at least producing them
and to make a long story short to skip a
number of years later to now being a
associate professor at Duke University
Medical Center teaching medical students
on how the brain works I recently
discovered in with my collaborators that
the brain pathways that control vocal
learning abilities are embedded within
brain areas that control motor sequence
behavior including the potentially
learning how to dance and so now I'm
actually coming full circle to bringing
my scientific career and my former dance
training together because those two
brain circuits seem to be related to
each other and I hope in the future to
discover what that relationship really
is and I think the answer is going to
tell us how brain pathways for complex
circuits evolve in general and this
would be a natural nice merging of art
and science
you